Yeah,
well,
Bom,
bom.
I'm really working hard on not being,
sorry,
ladies and gentlemen,
welcome Dac.
If this is your first voyage with us,
he picked a very strange part of the journey.
This is part two of the honey honey podcast,
part one.
There was a lot of alcohol and marijuana in the room,
allegedly,
and a,
some things we're sad.
We're not really sure what you said.
We don't even know what the fuck we said after it was over.
Like what are we okay?
Did they do anything wrong?
Give us another chance.
But a,
what is this whiskey that you find people have brought?
What does that mean?
Each y d means and fun times.
It does good talks in depth conversation.
They invented that shit when people thought dragons were real.
They were worried.
Dragons,
we're going to fly out of castles.
Fucking hammered drinking that.
Um,
but I'm pretty sure we're okay.
I don't think we said anything that fucked up.
No good.
But I'm not married to anything.
I just said it's easier that way.
I just want to let everybody know if I,
if I pissed you off,
I probably pissed me off too.
If I go off and listen to me while I'm sober,
I'm like shut up.
Shut the fuck up.
So I'm right there with Ya.
Just A,
we're just trying to do the best we can.
Ladies and gentlemen,
this strange,
strange world.
It's world we're spinning around.
Yeah.
They found water on Mars today.
Bitches.
Shit.
Just covering up the cake time NASA now.
Um,
we not me and you know,
don't do it Suzanne.
I won't let you guys go.
Fuck all that.
You bring the funny no Jamie,
you bring the food shows out too.
And the Cliche,
I say we stay in the spa.
That's already awesome.
There's not a lot of tiling nice here.
Like,
yeah,
this is the best spot we have ever seen.
We've been sending rockets in the spaces that I teed 50s.
This is the best part by far.
We ever tell you about our car.
The Escalade.
Yes,
I think so.
We went into the manual.
We've got a great deal on it.
We didn't want to buy a van.
We were like,
there's four of us we can.
That's a better move.
Fishers,
the user manuals,
how to use like all the fucking spaceship buttons,
former owner registration falls out.
Ben,
who was it set up?
Elon Musk.
Good Google worrying.
Now the government is spying on you.
Three Elon Musk's form a vehicle to keep tabs on you.
This is all like some sort of a scam.
Like Ilan Musk,
big fan of honey.
Honey band says,
listen guys,
I need you to take a Cadillac off my hands.
Make electric it electric Suv Ilan,
please.
That'd be great.
Thanks.
[inaudible] had to go buy clones signal the same one as in the back of my Tesla.
That goes zero to 60 in one second.
He's controlling the vehicle levies cars.
He's creating these cars that are literally like,
what's the most time you need speed?
The most time we need speed is like at a rate are running at a red light stop to
go or merging onto a highway.
Right?
Like if you're trying to merge onto a highway,
that's the only time you like legitimately need horsepowers.
She only time,
well this guy is creating a car that's in that way as fast as anything that you
could buy ever.
It's like a Ferrari ridiculously fast.
Maybe even faster than a Ferrari.
Nope.
Not Feeling it.
Yes.
If the apocalypse comes,
you're going to need gasoline shit.
You're gonna need to burn things.
Purpose to it though.
The electricity.
Amen.
Is that possible?
Yes.
If they can figure out solar to the point where they make some dope paint that's
also like solar collecting and is like a solar panel.
Like why is it solar panel?
We'll have to look like,
uh,
like the inside of an air conditioning filter.
Why did I switch stupid?
But I can't solar panels like dope.
Why can't the whole car be just solar panels?
You know,
why don't you make some slick ass fucking solar panels,
right?
Because on,
at Santos on it.
But I think if they did that,
older women,
they're working on it.
If they ever figure out a way to make a car that is an 100% solar in California,
like a Tesla,
like a really high end,
beautiful car that also you never need to plug in.
The batteries are so efficient.
I just,
I don't think they're that far away from that.
I mean,
when I say that far thing like a hundred years,
I don't think we're that far away.
I think they already know they're just hiding it because the gas situation is
government.
Joe Totally sucks.
That covers now I don't so out of the loop.
It's not enough time.
No,
that's all I'm saying in the day.
If you're tenacious d fan,
don't get mad at me.
I've enjoyed a lot of their work.
It's not what's going on here.
It's just not enough time to know that you had to pick,
pick your mom.
Too much fucking material out there and we're all making more of it.
Yeah.
That's like how we do it.
It makes them fucking more,
that's the craziest thing about music.
If you really stop and think about it at the break we were talking about
Beethoven and we're talking about um,
all the different notes and the,
the different things that they created way back then that you can still recreate
today.
That's just being able to notate,
you know,
we can play music that was invented before was recording technology or that was
the recording technology.
It's like this is how that sounds.
We'll figure out a way to write this and now you can interpret that and make the
same sound.
Right.
And if you go back to then how many people wrote music,
like what was the number of published works and like Beethoven's finest year,
Mozart,
was it mostly like people aren't fully aware of what Mozart actually wrote as
opposed to like his family members contributed and stuff.
Is that what you're saying?
That was box.
There's some of that.
There wasn't,
the point is there wasn't much,
there wasn't much notated,
at least cause he was an education to do that.
You needed tons of money.
You'd have to get people with serious money to sponsor your life,
you know?
And there just weren't that many tousled like that Tony Hawk,
Lance Armstrong thing where it's like there's a couple of famous dudes in that
field.
Everybody else.
Who the fuck?
Okay.
Beethoven.
Bach,
Mozart.
The dude's.
Okay.
There's like a couple other dudes that are like in the periphery.
That's like a three.
I got room for three or four major.
Yeah,
they're so fucking good though.
That's the thing about saying all these contributing factors to the environment
is like being an,
I was like Malcolm Gladwell's outliers.
It's like there's all these things that have to happen.
Like I'm sure there were other people that had these magical ears.
They just didn't have the resources to build it like Beethoven or Bach or Mozart
did.
And like,
you know,
if you like the arts,
like the Metta chief family who you know were benefactors to these people that
like flourished because of their incredible amount of wealth.
You know,
it's just certain things.
That was the chair.
I didn't fart.
Just making that clear.
It was like straight up.
I want to talk about this.
Here we are.
What happened to us?
They were so smooth.
We were so smooth on top of it.
We're still smooth.
Our feelings are like right up front and you know they're right there.
There's no need for us to talk about why you guys were upset at each other a few
days ago.
Definitely not.
We don't even talk about that and I need for,
I think we went through two and a half hours of awesome psycho analysis.
Go back and listen to that shit afterwards.
We're going to be like,
no,
you meant,
you said some really beautiful shit.
I'm not kidding for whether it's people want to listen to it or not.
We all lies on the spot
work.
We'll take the,
the front,
the falsified information.
You ever listen to classical music?
Speaking to Beethoven or anymore?
I try.
It's difficult side.
Sometimes I'm going to listen to it.
Like when I write I'll put on headphones on an airplane.
Yeah.
It's hard to navigate.
It's just so much shit and it's like,
you know,
historical at this point.
Like you gotta like really energizing though.
It's not like it's like,
did it like that doesn't like make you fall asleep.
That's like,
like,
oh my God,
let's get up.
It's also conquer the day.
The other problem with it is
like as a person who makes stuff,
I always look at it as like just some crazy cover band because it's not really
Mozart.
Mozart's dead.
It's fuck.
Yeah.
Like even if they're nailing it,
even if they're there,
they're nailing what he was asking for.
It's not him doing it.
Half of the Star spangled banner is not the noise [inaudible] wow.
Wow.
It's knowing that Jimi Hendrix did that at Woodstock in 1969 that's half of what
it is.
It's like the sound that I hear from a Sturgill Simpson song or a honey honey
song or fucking run DMC,
anybody.
It's like that's their shit and it's coming out of them.
It's not a cover band.
It's their words with their annunciations boom.
I mean,
that's what it is.
that's what I want.
I don't,
I don't want to hear like somebody recreating.
I understand it.
I mean,
I understand it that,
that it's compelling and amazing and artistic and so integral to the structure
of music,
even today,
interest not men.
That's really interesting to hear.
You know what I mean?
Because I come from a total or just desire to always fucking here.
That shouldn't be listening to music in a way to be like,
I don't know how to describe it I guess,
but in a way that's a different class of what you're talking about.
You know,
the idea of like,
you want to hear somebody express themselves.
I'm using,
he's fucking offers,
but I want to hear like when you're playing guitar,
I know those were,
that's been scratching those wires.
It's you doing that,
you know what I'm saying?
Like I hear you,
you know,
like you come through that and there's nothing wrong with the,
they didn't have the ability to transmit this information any other way.
Then write it down and notes,
sell these books that,
that,
uh,
that's it.
I mean,
it gets a hundred years,
200 years,
300 years.
It's the only way to do it.
Yeah.
It didn't have any other way,
but we have a better way now.
Yeah,
no,
you're right.
And this is,
it's funny,
there's a certain,
maybe it's not an indulgence.
Maybe it is,
but I was thinking about it while you said that.
It's like,
well,
I just like listening to those sounds.
You know what I mean?
Whether the motets making,
I just liked that sound,
you know?
Oh that's cool.
But it's also something that you do in your free time.
You have time to sit down and say,
I'm going to appreciate some sounds as opposed to what you're talking about.
It's like,
I'm going to hear a person.
You're right.
You know,
in in that sense I'm wrong because it's really two completely different things.
It's like one of them's a beautiful orchestration of sounds and the other one is
a person's like expression coming through.
Especially with the addition of language,
the addition of songs and song writing and the words like,
it's really almost,
it's like the difference between,
it's almost like completely different artistic endeavors.
Well,
it almost feels like those like Mozart sounds are like genetically passed down
or something.
Like they've been around for so long that like they become this like you feel
them in your body when you hear it.
It's like you hear,
you feel this like physical reaction to them in this way.
That and as,
as you do,
um,
song written vocal expressions.
But those are,
they're so old that there's something really interesting that happens from this
traditional reaction to it.
You know?
No one I think would be the shit.
No,
what
crash from the float lab and Venice develop some crazy underwater speaker system
that's waterproof.
Oh yeah.
He's such a wizard.
Oh my God.
It's fucking dude created that.
And he also has been working like forever on this idea of a screen that amidst
the lowest amount of light possible,
so that needs to be suspended from you in front of your face when you're a in
the tank.
And you could see these images almost like they're floating in the air.
Like you can't see a television.
You only see the images in this,
this sensory deprived situation you fic.
But he's got the speakers that he has figured out how to submerge like in the
water next to you.
It's incredible.
Crazy,
and it gives you the stereo sound in the water where it vibrates off of your
body.
Like you feel it,
you feel it on your arms and your legs.
You feel it.
Uh Huh.
Yeah.
I mean that's,
and that's what it all is,
which is such a crazy,
it's just one.
Um,
what's it?
Oh,
crazy.
Yeah.
Playing the sounds.
I was like,
I want to hear them.
I've never done it.
I haven't done this.
A new system he's got,
yeah,
but he's a,
he's always trying to innovate,
but in the,
in that way he said that you feel the music,
you feel it through the line,
which is fascinating.
Yeah.
I did that music.
If it's done through one of those things,
like this is just one step.
This guy's got a couple of speakers.
What if they insert them through the entire base of an isolation tank and then
program music like,
like they,
they do those South American Eco rose with the shamans when they do the IOWASCA
ceremony.
Some therapy would,
if they figured out a way to like get you into some fucking crazy trans,
like we were talking about how houses have certain frequencies and then make you
go nuts.
You know,
maybe there's like a certain one,
some people do like some
Jimi Hendrix did that and he talks about it sometimes.
Like you get five minutes,
six minutes into some of this music he's making and people kind of fall into a
different state.
You know,
there's a different place.
I guess what I'm saying,
it's like people are looking for it and a lot of musicians,
that's what is based on,
you know,
it's like how can I make this shit shake to kind of cast a spell without,
maybe that's not the best way to put it,
but it's like I'm trying to affect you with rat and you can do it in
intentionally almost.
I think it's like you go to a different place.
You know,
if you,
if you're like really trying to,
trying to do something like that,
it's like a weird,
maybe I sound
crazy things that we do it all the time.
Maybe you don't think about it that way,
but what you're doing is trying to connect with people and express yourself when
you're doing it like vibrationally fucking hippie tall
man,
Bruh.
It's hippy talk.
I agree with.
That's the problem with AP talk comes from the mouth of hippies occasionally.
Goddammit.
You discredit a discrediting all these interesting ideas.
Um,
you guys want to play some music?
Sure.
Let's do it.
We won't apply.
I'm going to put bad people.
Sure.
Tell me the punk kid story because I'm frustrated.
What are you frustrated about?
Because I love that song.
That song is not died.
We you want to hear a song first?
Yes.
Okay.
Whatever you want to do.
Let's play bad people.
I'm going to take these off and thinking.
Is that Okay Jamie?
I'll just sing.
We just want put it on our next record.
Yeah.
Okay.
Good move.
The legend will grow there or some record company in congruencies that like,
I know you weren't able to do the things we wanted with it and it's a really
tested it by saying,
wait,
good move.
It's a good song.
It's a,
it's a weird song to song.
It's got a lot of layers to it.
It's a lot going on.
What going on in that song?
What a weird shit.
Good.
Go.
Can I,
we can we just do it?
Yeah.
Recording.
Hi in the gay keyboard.
Mouse Front Yard
in Paul.
So I got to city
judge your best to be the worst you must like,
hey,
that show of Kirsten.
Okay.
Hello.
Oh,
okay.
Ah,
Jimmy,
was it broken?
Sangoma Outta Ellen nut bread.
Like a pit bull on your butt.
Crack down his nose.
He was bloody all his life.
[inaudible] Abu Dammit.
They cashed the check and he won't know.
Lovers leftover friends.
So it's fine.
Is it Dan?
Hey,
bang in a burner
chimney.
Miss up our sleeves and we all got some darkness up our sleeve.
Hmm.
Some pulls down and some push through
baby.
It's a toss up.
How you do maybe some on the sides for you.
Maybe you don't even get
and a dog,
no
crash and
the bang and a burner.
The boat off come from
come from.
No,
God damn you got
both of you.
Both of you for being so awesome.
God Damn,
that was good.
You know it was really cool.
People that are listening to this only you don't know that Suzanne adjusted
Ben's glasses in the middle of the song.
It's Ben's glasses started to slip and Suzanne like Lego.
It's like a mama bear set you straight in.
It happens some but it in the middle of like singing without missing a beat.
It was beautiful.
You were like looking for the moment to reach towards his face.
Hello?
Coming in.
I'm coming down and wash my hair by down his nose and there's nothing you can do
about it,
but she can't break those scanned and one of them rubber band things.
Nah Man,
I'm looking for him.
He didn't do like a strap.
Yeah Dude.
Just something like we snap down like a ski goggles
one day there's going to have a shot just going to shoot something in your eye
balls and they're going to be,
no,
he doesn't want that.
My dad gets that.
He's terrified.
He's got macular degeneration so we get injections in his eyeball.
Oh yes.
It's crazy.
Lord.
You think about,
I think about that sometimes.
Like if you could either go blind,
right,
or get hypodermic needles shot into your eyes every month,
month,
every month.
Every month.
Okay.
Yeah.
Maybe there's some not a,
okay,
and you're so tough.
No,
it's anybody's ever answer.
It doesn't say that he's hardcore.
Remember he's medium cords saying no,
no,
no.
You're a poser
Amar court,
bro.
All's part of the hardcore hardcore scene.
There was hardcore guys.
There's a bunch of guys didn't believe that.
The guys who were calling us don't worry.
A lot of leather
or suede.
I wore this kind of squared like that I should have wore off.
I was like on a stage coach in the 17 hundreds of tassels,
tassels.
I wore moccasins only wanted a tip throats.
You Woods making shit up.
Moccasins seemed cool.
I wish I were more,
it's interesting how like all you have to do is we're a dead animal skin in a
dark color and you're a rebel,
you know like the black leather jacket and the 1950s especially with the little
silver buttons.
Well that's what I love about Poeboy.
I think there's some really interesting things in there.
Like people have these like connections to certain elements of like what you put
on shore.
I think it's fascinating.
That's why you need all you people out there.
Need to respect rob Halford.
Okay.
Is that Rob Halford to Judas priest.
Oh,
dare you.
No breakdown
Scott.
Another thing is sheltered life.
I mean that guy,
uh,
was probably one of the first openly gay singers have a fucking a band when it
opened.
Right?
A metal pan and he got everybody to dress like him.
Mother daddies.
You guys thought you were metal?
Well,
you really were the same thing.
[inaudible]
it was web.
Brilliant.
Yeah.
That's how bad ass he was.
I had him on one of them.
I did this show once
it's for ESP or not ESPN VH one.
And uh,
he was one of the guests on the show.
I'll get to hang out with that guy for like an hour.
It was cool.
So cool.
But it was so weird.
It was like,
God damn,
I'm tall.
I'm senior talking to rock and roll royalty.
You know when I was in high school,
I had this friend that was obsessed with Judas priest.
I think I'll let them sit around
and wait until we had this fucking kid.
Man.
It's his life saw his life sucked.
His Dad's suck.
His situations sucked.
You got another thank God.
Dot.
That that fucking song.
You got another thing coming fueled that dude through high school.
I swear to God it though.
That's the crazy thing about what you guys do.
Like music can be heard it like it feels like you can eat,
it's like fuel.
There's something to it.
Like it didn't,
Hunter Thompson had a,
he had uh,
an amazing quote about that.
He thinks of music as inspiration or is it fuel heath?
I think he said fuel and he said that when you listen to it,
you swear that you can get 'em shittily paraphrasing what he said,
but it was like you could,
you feel like you could drive further on an empty tank of gas that you can just
keep going.
Like it'll allow you to go at 20% longer or something like that.
I forget what his actual quote was,
but it's like that's true.
Like there's something happens man,
when a song you've got
don like you feel stronger,
right?
If you were at the gym,
it sounds also like bringing you back to this place that you'll never like that
always bring you back.
They're like,
they'll bring you back to like this childhood of like,
nobody can fucking touch that.
Like this summer I,
every time I listened to the fucking this song,
you know,
it brings it back to this time where I'm like,
it almost makes you giddy.
Hunter s town.
Here's the code.
Music has always been a matter of energy to me.
A question of fuels.
Sentimental people call it inspiration,
but what it really means is fuel.
I have always needed fuel.
I'm a serious consumer on some nights.
I still believe the car with the gas needle on empty can run about 50 more miles
if you have the right music.
Very loud on the radio purpose.
Beautiful border.
I butchered that.
I haven't read that
paraphrase job.
Ac DC,
ac DC.
For me it was a suicidal tendencies.
You can't bring me down cause the greatest weightlifting song at all.
I swear to God I'm 10% stronger.
You can
never heard of suicidal tendencies.
Absolutely.
Fuck yeah.
Right.
Yeah.
Venice and they would come in and play some time course that you can't bring me
down.
Anybody who listens to that you can lift more weights.
You become stronger,
you become stronger.
You can be angry.
Sorry,
sorry to interrupt,
but that gave me a question in my mind.
How do you feel?
I just learned about estrogen blockers.
Okay.
How do you feel about
estrogen?
I feel the same way that I have like with Roach motels there.
If you need them,
you should get them.
Okay.
I mean,
just blew my mind the other way.
He was like,
I don't know.
I mean,
uh,
if you have a headache,
you should get aspirin.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
What's going on,
man?
I was talking to somebody about building muscle and he was like,
Dude,
you should,
uh,
the real problem with those things is what their,
the,
the with a really good for is if someone is coming off of a steroid,
because when you take a steroid,
your endocrine system suffers,
stops producing testosterone and this,
these things,
like they're called,
like Clomid is one of m and a,
there's a couple of other different companies that make a similar product and it
increases your body's ability to reap,
to produce testosterone.
It has this like affection blocking the estrogen.
You produce more testosterone,
your body tries to seek some sort of a balance.
He sort
of trick it.
Yeah.
I think we know so little about what,
what does and doesn't like work for you.
Like is it,
there's a lot of experimentation going on like,
well,
maybe he needs a this or maybe he needs out of that.
How old is he?
What's his background?
But you can get this stuff over the counter.
Right.
It's like,
what have you done before you decided to do that?
This is the like if anybody ever wants to do something,
if they ever want to go,
hey man,
I'm thinking about getting into a hardcore workout program.
How many days in a row have you worked out?
Be honest me.
No,
no,
no.
This is why I set those dude too.
I'm like,
dude,
you fuck you.
Fuck her.
Listen,
if you want to,
if you want to start running marathons,
you've got to run every day.
But she,
okay,
I can't just keep talking to you.
You're talking nonsense.
Yeah.
Right.
And if you're saying,
well,
I'm thinking about taking estrogen blockers.
How many days do you lift weights?
How often?
How sore are you?
A little bit sore.
Okay,
but I don't even do that.
Say never going to work the thing if you wanted,
but if you want to do it,
the first thing you do before you think about estrogen blockers are in a hurry.
It's just be consistent.
It's the most important thing.
It's more important than anything.
It's more important even than the amount of weight that you lift.
It's the frequency in which you engage in the act of going to the gym and
exerting yourself.
Cause if you can consistently do it every time,
we talked to this earlier but I'd do it,
but this is,
this is plastic and available daily,
but you could just take this shit and from no,
no,
no.
You need prescription.
They do need a good ass unless it doesn't work.
I mean unless it's fake fake ones.
The people may forgive my ignorance,
but is this anything that like transgender people would take to?
No,
no,
no.
It's a different,
it's really to try to stimulate growth of,
to stimulate the reproduction of testosterone by like trying to fuck with the
balance.
Like by suppressing estrogen,
you sort of try to elevate your body elevates us.
Todd.
There's like some wrestling match going on cause they need hardcore chemicals.
Yeah.
They need bio identical hormones that are in whatever gender they identify with.
I decided to transition into,
which is one of the,
I mean objectively nonjudgmentally but objectively it's one of the oddest things
about the whole idea.
Well,
it's not just that like this is who you are.
It's like this is who you are.
Also putting hormones in your body to become what it would,
it seems like you feel like you should be.
So there's a,
there's many layers and and totally nonjudgmental,
judgemental sense.
No one's telling you to not do it at all,
but there's,
there's a lot going on there.
It's not just identifying with something,
it's choosing to transitioned into,
so there's a lot,
it's like there's some serious complexity to all of this and in a nonjudgmental
way.
It's very fascinating.
It's very fascinating that we're coming more and more comfortable with it
because ultimately isn't it really when it's all over?
Ultimately,
what do I,
who gives a fuck?
Like jokes aside,
laughing,
assigned a serious hot debates.
Who cares if you want to be a man,
if you want to be a woman,
if you want to be both,
you want to switch back and forth.
There was a guy on one of the NPR,
it was not in a radio lab.
Okay.
I was switches back and forth.
He's like,
sometimes he's a woman.
I'm a man now.
He just is because in his head,
the way he identifies,
he was like two different people in his head.
One of them's man and then it becomes a woman and in the middle of the things
goes,
I just switched.
I just flipped here like he's talking,
he's people like I'm a man now and we were like,
what?
You can just do that again?
This isn't it possible.
He's crazy.
Like isn't it possibly he's making shit up.
Do we have electrodes?
And like sometimes he's like,
what is he thinking about dicks?
It's all decks.
Sometimes it's vaginas.
Agendas now,
well I mean there's an emotional mental screening process for people that want
to go like full throttle with the like Dick to v d two D to d switch it up.
Unfortunately like pretty certificated.
It's surgery and I think there's gonna come a really interesting time where
they're able to manipulate what you are in a way that's non,
not like as primitive as cutting and stitching things back up together.
But maybe like somehow or another altering what you actually are like changing.
Like the signal that your cells have and what shape you want it to form.
I mean I don't think that's outside of the the possibilities.
You know,
what about transmitting consciousness to different body because people do talk
about that while we're also recognizing that your body's not,
it's what you need it while you're using it,
but it's not all of you and that the idea of who you are when you're not even
connected to your body like that might be the real you and what what this body
thing is is it's like this,
you have this like biological thing that you're attached to if sort of evolved
with you and in just the same way you have all this weird bacteria on your skin
and weird flora and your intestines.
That might be exactly what like life and the body is and that the consciousness
in the body,
they,
they're the really the,
they're kind of the same thing but not really the same way.
Like the things that are growing in your body.
All the millions and billions and trillions of microbes and life forms that live
in every one of us.
Those are,
you know,
and we don't want to think that they're all,
they're not even important if without them you're fucked.
Just cause you can talk.
It doesn't mean they're not in on the whole thing.
You know,
you're a giant collection of living,
you know,
it's incredible.
Fuck,
we're crazy.
We're so odd.
It makes me think of the planet thing.
You know,
all of a sudden all these gases,
all this shit's just boom,
smacks together and then it's the thing or it was a thing before.
Now the form changes.
But like the fuck is it?
Why is the center burning up?
I Dunno.
I'm not,
I'm too dumb for that.
Me Too.
You don't like those zones?
She dumped four k like,
like water on Mars.
Like,
hmm,
what water?
Ice.
What is it?
I can get those concepts.
I understand.
I've seen water melts.
I've seen it get cold.
I've seen icicles on Mars.
Could you imagine if they really did find a life form on Mars?
Haven't they found bacterias and like microscopic things think they found
evidence of biology
in my very rudimentary way of understanding what those guys are talking about.
I think they find like there's certain cities,
nature,
uh,
patterns that they can find that might indicate some sort of biological life at
some point in time.
But I don't think they found a smoking gun.
I don't think they found like a fossil or am I right,
Jamie?
Does that make sense?
And there's the potential that there's like forms of life that we cannot
identify as as humans.
Like,
like aren't like these,
you know,
physical elements.
But that it's like almost something that you just can't see,
smell,
taste or touch,
you know,
it's like,
oh,
it might be,
and this is going to be the craziest thing to say.
It might be that everything's alive.
It might,
it might be that everything that you encounter reacts in some sort of a weird
way.
But we are so rigid in our idea of what's alive,
what's not alive or what's conscious and not shot,
but retains energy.
And what doesn't that we don't think about it.
We don't think about like objects and how well the,
you know,
this,
the psychics talk about like multidimensional planes and stuff and I dunno,
I know.
I don't,
I don't know where you stand on this stuff,
but I think they're mostly bullshit,
bullshit stuff.
But there's also stuff that I've seen that I'm,
I can't explain and I'm like,
what the fuck is that?
You know?
Yeah,
no,
I know exactly what you mean.
You never know what to talk about it right now.
But it's like we were talking about the ghost hunting shows earlier.
I don't not believe in like that guy a,
what's his name?
Zack Baggins.
He's,
he seems like a nice guy.
I've watched the show for it.
Entertaining.
He goes looking for ghosts.
Can I tell you some ghost stories?
Here's,
here's the go story.
Okay.
So my dad,
uh,
running this restaurant with my uncle since he was 17.
He kills a man with ax.
Not Lately,
but we didn't pay for up.
You said sauce.
Um,
but my dad was telling me this story that,
um,
uh,
I wasn't that long ago that this family that's been coming into the restaurant
for years and years and years,
um,
came in and he saw everybody,
he saw,
you know,
mom,
Dad,
kids,
beautiful grandmother shining the back.
And he said,
oh,
he guys,
party of five.
And they said,
nope,
just for,
and,
and he told like this,
you know,
it's like Dad,
like my dad is not going to fucking make shit up.
And he said he felt
this incredible,
like the,
the grandmother was standing behind the family,
like just like looking so happy.
And he was like,
okay,
four.
And then he said,
he,
he like looked away and she was gone and he sat the family down and,
and he,
he was really freaked out and he like,
he was kind of like,
you know,
doing other stuff.
And he,
he came back and he said,
hey,
how's your,
how's your mom doing?
And they said,
oh,
well,
she passed a couple months ago and he had this moment where he,
he was like,
I felt like I should tell them.
And he did and he said,
I feel really uncomfortable,
but I,
I really feel like I need you to know that when you came into the restaurant,
I saw your mother standing behind you guys.
And,
and they didn't kind of,
they didn't freak out and they,
they just said,
we really feel like she's still with us.
And,
and that's not the first time my dad's had a weird ghost story at the
restaurant.
He's had a few other experiences.
And when you talked about it,
he was kind of like,
yeah,
I s I fucking saw her.
Like I saw her.
So your dad saw the old lady behind them?
Yeah.
And how old was your dad at the time?
This was like last year.
A couple of years ago.
Like it wasn't that long ago.
And um,
wow.
Yeah,
it's,
look,
if,
if you can have people,
like,
if the idea that goes to ridiculous,
why is it,
why is it any more ridiculous than an echo?
Yeah.
You ever get under a bridge and yell,
hello?
Hello?
Hello.
Why is that weirder than ghosts?
It's not right.
It's a ghost.
Could be just as likely could be like your,
your,
your actual life form whenever it was,
when you went.
Sure.
I mean it might like Echo,
we underestimate how powerful our energy is.
I mean,
people can leave a real impression that people can stay with you.
Like literally like have you ever had somebody who just like fucking kicked your
ass energetically and you left a place and you're like,
God,
I just feel like there's still with me,
like,
like that stuff is not to be taken lightly.
I think.
And it can be the absolute opposite end of the spectrum of joy and love and
kindness and you can get energy in these places.
And I think some people can have an innate ability to us to interpret it in a
different way where they are maybe actually see it or the hear it or whatever.
You know,
cause I believe my Dad,
I love my dad.
I believe him.
You know,
it's totally possible that someone can actually see an aura.
But if you can't take a photo of it,
I'm just have,
I just have to bank on the fact you know,
out of your fucking mind,
you know to date we've talked to my dad and he'll ask him,
I don't know.
And go screen screen all around him is green.
Green is like,
I see him,
I see his arm.
There are people,
things like that.
It's purple.
You don't,
what is that from?
It's from almost famous.
Oh,
okay.
Was
One movie,
right?
So is that like the cautionary tale for the young Rockstar?
I that's probably the tempting tent,
right?
Yeah.
I don't know if we'll ever get there,
but maybe
you don't want to get there.
You want to get like in the neighborhood,
you want to get like a adjacent
from that guy.
You don't have the time.
Did we start this podcast earlier than seven 45
party that now it's been awhile.
You guys want to play another song?
W we should,
but I also want to play our sweet thing video.
I feel like we should play it first.
It's fucking awesome.
Okay,
let's play it.
It's,
it's on our,
it's um,
Jamie,
the links on our Twitter page,
ladies and gentlemen,
Dat,
Dat Dah,
Dah.
Man,
we did this video guys.
We didn't this,
you guys are awesome.
What is this?
We did this official video,
Dave Gruber Allen.
Well,
we have to be careful.
We don't want you to flag us off of Youtube with this.
Will you get in trouble?
You might.
You guys might have some like really overly enthusiastic regular company.
Ooh.
Do you have a good record company or is your record company very
by the book?
We have not litigious.
Um,
then happy come into the office to give them permission to saying and play sweet
thing on their power lapsed.
Who says we do?
I would like you guys to say it into the microphone that no
forming the entire answer.
Honey.
Yeah.
All right.
Rolling.
Sexy Bitch.
Oh,
nice.
Speeding
through my tab.
Oh,
if you're not watching this,
there's an old dancing.
He's got white hair,
long beard and long hair and these signings,
everything is Suzanne sings in a sexy gyrating way.
Does look at him.
I can't wait until
this far.
See?
Oh my God.
Makes me
sick.
That is awesome.
That's a fun video.
What is it about videos where when you watch some shit that makes it look really
old,
it becomes better?
Like all the,
like the little scratchy things that made it seem like it was like an old movie.
Yeah.
Why has it become better?
What does that,
what does that call to nostalgia and a mood,
you know,
mood,
make it familiar.
Who is the old dude that was dancing?
He was on Uber.
Who's groover?
Dave Gruber Allen is,
he was,
um,
he's famous for a few things.
He was on a show called freaks and Geeks,
um,
a Judd Apatow show.
He played the guidance counselor,
so there's like this weird like cult following,
but he was also the naked trucker on comedy central and he's done a lot of
really great work,
but he's also been a really great friend of ours over the years.
When I first moved to La,
I'd moved into a house and was,
he was my house maintenance.
It's like crazy intro to the city.
I was 18.
I moved in and he was much older and just like,
it kind of,
I got to see all this great comedy that I never,
like.
I'd never gone to a comedy club when I was a kid and they didn't have that where
I was,
where I grew up.
Excuse me.
Um,
and,
uh,
I was going to this club and in La and seeing all these dudes like him and
Patton Oswald was doing Largo,
Largo guys.
There's this great,
yeah,
he's,
he's in that,
yeah.
That's a very unusual video.
Yes.
Oh,
cool.
look a little more on the bow.
How pretty consistent with our videos.
The house had been lived in and I lived in,
again,
it's kind of like this artist compound and like Jim Turner,
um,
owns a house I really good friend and he was our angel of death and our angel of
death video.
Um,
but like he was also Randy of the redwoods on MTV.
This is fun to do shit with your friends.
And I mean,
that's what we keep doing over and over when we have a project,
people who just want to do with our friends.
Yeah.
It's,
it makes it,
yeah.
It makes everything more fun.
Doable.
Yeah.
It changes what the thing is.
The thing goes from being a labor to a party.
Yeah.
And Jim,
Jim and,
and Gruber are like our family to us.
So when we get to make fucking silly videos with them and whether people like it
or not,
like we,
we love it.
It's so fun,
you know?
Yeah.
I mean it's one of the coolest things that you can,
when you do things like that today,
you could just,
you could distribute them in a way that you'd never would be able to just a
decade ago,
two decades,
three decades go.
You know,
it was,
you guys were people in the music business especially,
we're so dependent upon like traveling and getting a reputation,
you know,
and word of mouth.
I know in some bands like became gigantic just through word of mouth.
Like that was like a big thing.
Back when we were kids.
It was like underground music.
Like if you found that,
if you knew about the creeps,
do you know about the crepes?
I like people knew.
They knew.
People knew about it like he had it.
No,
yeah,
no.
Someone,
you know,
if you wanted to hear about some cool shit to this,
is this top of the run DMC?
Do you know who Kool g rap is?
Do you know Kool g rap is,
you need to know,
I need to get you a fucking demo tape.
You know,
there was like some dudes that were like these underground dudes and knowing who
they were was like crucially important.
Oh yeah.
Especially if folks in Jamie's generation,
right.
Crucially important to know who's he's very,
he'll like say with like enthusiasm.
He'll inform me of the new hot players in the rap genre and a,
I've done,
okay,
so this is the guy now.
Okay.
And what's his deal?
Can you fill us in later widget?
He knows.
Okay.
Awesome.
James on the ball doing it.
Oh Man.
This has been educational,
informational and really fun.
Inspirational poem.
The end that was my boy knocking in.
You know,
I know.
If I said,
can I read my poem?
You'd been like,
oh Christ.
You'd have to see you inside.
Joke from podcast number one.
Hey Joe,
can we tell the people that were on tour right now?
Oh Fuck yes you can.
We're on tour right now guys.
We're going to be going through Texas and uh,
we're playing.
Ben,
help me out here in New Orleans.
We're in Tennessee,
in Nashville or in southwest.
Next couple of days we'll be in Santa Fe.
Powerful Santa friend,
honey.
Any band.com if you want to fucking get in on this,
we're going to be playing a whole bunch until about mid November.
What does the Twitter,
Twitter is honey,
honey band,
honey,
honey band is to ram honey,
honey.
There we are.
There's a lot of stuff going on.
We'd love to see you guys out there in the world.
The real world.
Maybe a little bit too much.
Yeah,
we get physical,
so yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
A lot of flailing.
We both got accosted by this woman in mom recently and he was good.
It was amazing.
He see all of a sudden I was like,
she was kissing my neck and I was like,
oh,
hold on a second.
You need to buy me things first.
How bad their breast milk now.
She was really beautiful,
but I was also,
she was just so aggressive and I felt like a fucking piece of meat and I was
like,
let's,
let's not,
let's just calm down,
you know,
I want to be treated nicely.
That's awesome.
That's right.
Have you been linked?
I have a very strong husband.
Heisman
assumed the highest one.
Can't let them get close enough to turn you into a Zombie
on the walking dead.
And they were like,
oh no,
no,
no bitch.
If you're in the middle of the football field with a Zombie,
okay,
they're not,
you're not going to get me.
No.
Okay.
You're not,
I'm fast too fast.
Just shoot right for the head.
I know you do.
Yeah,
but if I have a gun,
but I'm saying like,
it was just me and the Zombie,
like,
um,
this isn't 28 days later.
28 days to fucking terrifying to those.
They get you,
you got to go slow movers walking into,
I'll fuck those dudes up.
What was he?
They were moving fast,
but in the book and the books and the audio tapes,
which we listened to on toward,
they were slow.
When I saw the movie scared the fuck out of me.
I will head kick the fuck out of a Zombie.
I'll tell you right now,
let's talk about style zombies.
I warm up with some software to the body moving and then once I feel like this
dummy,
he's going to just walk right into a wheel kick.
I'm gonna try to take a Zombie's head off,
tried to kick a Zombie.
Right.
I wonder sometimes when people like Halloween time when people like to fuck with
each other and someone who's like,
I'm going to dress up like a Zombie and scare people,
but if they like take it to an extreme,
like if someone would actually like go crazy on them because the fear of zombies
is so great.
Oh,
people have been killed by that in the south really by being a fake Zombie
zombies impersonator.
Hundred percent don't do it.
That's really dumb.
I was in Montana right around the time.
It was like between like maybe six months before,
six months after I was in Montana,
this happened.
Some dude put on one of those,
um,
suits,
one of those suits call the Ghillie suits.
Is that what it's called?
Ghillie suit?
He put on like a camouflage suit.
It's like this crazy camouflage suit were dudes were in the military to hide
into,
or sometimes people use it for extreme hunting situations.
You,
you like pretend to be one of the bushes and then you jump out and get people.
This guy did it in pretending to be big foot.
So he put this Ghillie suit on and stood by a Bush.
And then when people were on the highway,
stepped out into the highway and no,
what happened?
This fucking teenage girl accelerated into him and killed bigfoot.
She sent bigfoot flying.
And then here's where it gets even crazier.
Another teenage driver going the opposite direction.
Dan ran over him again,
double teenager.
This is real story telling you the true story.
It's a real story.
A man and a Ghillie suit.
Is that,
am I saying it right?
If I,
I apologize if I'm getting it wrong.
I thought it was a Ghillie suit.
It looks like a bunch of leaves.
Like you're like you're connected string and Lee,
you know what I'm talking about?
Like a flocking Walberg and that movie crowd.
This guy put that on too far.
Guys.
You can't have safety with our prey curry,
but don't you think that that is the universe's way of eliminating idiots if you
really stopped and thought about it?
Like what type of a person?
Like what type of person goes,
you know what I'm going to do?
I'm going to say my day fucking with people.
I'm going to wait til it gets dark.
I'm going to put on the camera.
I'm going to jump in the middle of the road because it's going to be awesome.
Cool.
Tiny bit crazy.
Boom.
Done.
I mean,
maybe I think about that a lot with,
with uh,
these like,
you know,
haunted houses that people like sign up to go in and have people fuck with you.
Like I want no part of it.
I don't want some stranger touching me with a fake chainsaw.
Like I it,
it,
the physical reaction is terror.
I don't have to do it.
You don't have to do like who?
Like the people that are doing that I think have to be a little fucking askew in
the brain.
Like there's something weird with like,
I'm sorry,
it could be old fashioned fun.
Flickery I pride myself on like,
you know,
putting fake blood all over myself and just like getting people to shit their
pants.
I mean it's a job and it's like that or night fry guy at Wendy's.
What's a Guy gonna do when you'd rather be that job?
Yeah,
I think that scare the fuck out.
Some kids has a $9 an hour production dollar an hour.
It gives us little kids nightmares.
I'll do it violently.
A family.
Remember there's always denied.
Everybody might trauma.
So the kid was,
what the fuck just happened?
I can't change their lives.
Paul Little eight year old.
That's how you get that $9 an hour.
You only get seven at fucking one says all she got to commit though.
Dude that was good.
Once that extra dose
kids got to suffer,
they an adult summer camp,
you can go sleep over and do that like for two nights,
not a lake and all that.
Like did you ever,
did you ever see the documentary Jesus camp?
Yeah.
Well bits and pieces.
You've seen it,
right?
It's crazy.
It's amazing.
It's like sort of the opposite of the devil camp.
I'm sure there is and it should be equal time and all that good stuff.
Maybe they got some points,
but it was a documentary on these people that we're taking these kids and turn
them into radical fundamentalist because they were like their,
their logic was we need Christian warriors because they're already developing
Islamic warrior.
People are tweeting about that.
It's got rallying Christian army.
Whoa,
settle the fuck down.
So you want to tell them,
oh saying,
oh,
I'll just take it.
That's what's up.
Right.
Take a breath.
Everybody's like,
please.
Whenever you watch that shit that's going on in the Middle East,
be heading this and that and fucking stoning this and that,
like cheap it over there,
please keep it,
cut it out.
That's the one thing that people don't want to address in this world.
When the world of this parts of the world that are just really,
really fucked up for some reason,
as long as it's not right here,
we just talk about it changes.
Practice.
Facts I know were so strange.
Just the human animals so strange and we think we're having a bad day.
You know our bad days or ride show.
Oh my God,
I'm having a hard time quitting diet coke.
Let's talk about that.
No,
I'm not.
I'm just saying like that's like someone freaking out.
This is bullshit.
My [inaudible] teacher is an asshole.
I'm fucking,
I don't want to hear Duran Duran anymore.
These there a problem.
Okay.
Lucky people,
a bunch of local people here.
I think people when they were alive are lucky.
If you think about the amount of people that have died and the fact that you're
not one of them,
you should be really fucking happy.
It was lucky it shit.
Yeah,
we're all lucky.
It's a perspective,
that perspective issue and the disenchantment with your own,
your own position in the perspective.
That's like what fueled the whole thing.
It's like it's unavoidable in some way.
If I say like one more time I'll smack myself.
It's
like man,
like I hear myself saying,
I was like,
shut up bitch,
let me know what you sound like.
Rich
extra liked
you could fall into those things.
No,
no.
We're all lucky as fuck.
And uh,
I think uh,
you know,
hopefully that trend will continue.
I mean we really nice if the people next after we're done look back at us,
like the way we look at those coven wagon Douche bags,
you know,
we look at those covered wagon Douche bags like,
oh my God,
you didn't have medicine he had bark to do.
If somebody broke their leg,
broke my hand him with a rock and you might've went back to eat them.
Keep pulling.
Well,
did a lot of eating people back in those days.
That's when we should like,
that's how you get to judge civilization.
Like how much cannibalism per capita,
the Donner pass.
And I was thinking about that and I was like,
Danner,
Robin Williams,
he's like dinner 30 of that party of four.
They didn't even know where they were going.
They didn't have topographic map.
Crazy could've have just kept getting worse.
Why would this so cocky?
They didn't even know America was there,
right?
They were in the wrong spot.
They,
when you think about the people that landed in the West indies,
that's where they landed,
right?
The fact that they were so confident and not even knowing that the North America
existed,
they were in totally wrong spot and then they move across North America.
They get to these mountains,
they get to these insane rocky mountains,
these immense peaks like what's the highest,
what is it like 11,015 years this up there,
and they just go,
okay,
let's go there.
Let's keep going.
No,
we'll figure it out.
Animals to people ratio at that point.
It's not even cold up there,
dude.
Keep going.
Stop bringing up pause.
Puzzler like what does it do?
They know for sure what was on the other end?
Like what's the store?
No,
I mean that's whole Lewis and Clark.
Then they were looking for a passage.
They're like,
this could be here.
We hope this is here.
But the Donner party is that,
what was that story?
Because the Donner party had people already gone through.
There was a lot of families and I think,
I think it was like,
I want to say like 50 people went through and like 20 people made it out pull.
That didn't make it were for a fuel for the rest of the journey.
Oh my God.
Please quote me on incorrectly.
Correct you right?
Yeah.
But she says,
how bad must it have been where they were that they wanted to take that chance?
I Dunno.
I feel like I'd just be like,
time next buyer.
Do you see gold?
Was it a gold rush thing?
I Dunno.
I think it was people really desperately looking for their,
you know,
like this is our place.
We need to find our place.
Come on though.
We'll do whatever we needed to do.
Because you imagined the one person that was like just not that fucking Gung Ho
for this trip.
You're hanging
back and like to young gun rather they're tying down the wagon.
Right.
Give me a hand
in the legs.
I think it's,
you start with the meat parts.
You know the hide.
I'd be like,
well,
it's hind legs.
Smeta was where all the animals aren't shifts.
Let's go back to the light.
Yeah,
it would suck that I just had a deal.
What should I put me first deal.
It's my idea.
I'm going to tell us to go over the mountain,
so if it all goes back,
I'll let you bash my head in with a rock and you can eat me.
No,
you have to die naturally first like starvation.
Well then you don't have a lot of meat.
I don't know.
It's this tough.
This is really tough for fucking Alva.
Only the strong survive type shit from Suzanne.
Yeah.
You just kind of like get a little bit of the beginning off the bone.
Just say right now you're going to eat your grandma.
You're going to have to eat grandma.
She's going to die first.
Why?
Right.
That's what I'm saying.
Why did she say that?
Because that's what's going to happen.
This is like some Grapes of Wrath.
Shit.
Unless you decide this is sacrilege,
you know,
take the blessing.
I'm saying.
That's what I'm saying.
Cause I want to get some dinner.
Sure.
Absolutely.
You guys don't play any more songs.
We can add whatever you want.
Yeah.
Um,
what you going to do now?
Yeah,
we can do that.
We got a new version of it.
They're just popping off version.
We just play a little differently.
Oh my God.
You guys are crazy.
Powerful podcast number two.
Damn.
What is that part of the violin called a bow.
I know
also served as a hunt animals with it.
You just Kinda have to redirect it,
but it can also make sound the violin,
breaking it down.
Check our website for more details.
Really
out of tune.
But
I wish I could play the fiddle sees how many different things can you play?
I play guitar,
drums.
I can play piano a little bit.
Basically.
Really similar to guitar,
$50 an hour.
A lot of things.
It's how much different is,
I mean obviously besides the physical movement,
we'll talk later.
He still us to play the drums.
I don't think you should play the drums.
Band is an excellent drummer.
He wouldn't like state competition.
I only have a certain amount of resources dedicated towards hitting things.
Lesson one and done deal man.
I just want you guys to stay straight,
stay steady,
being awesome and uh,
I'll enjoy.
Enjoy what you're doing.
Okay.
I think I'm good.
Then how do you feel about your toneage?
I feel pretty good,
but I'm not really paying much attention.
Okay.
Keep it.
We're to do this.
We're going to do this.
I hope the people out there.
Okay.
This is a lengthy is they're going to be fine.
We're not committing way to any of this.
That's good.
Yeah.
That's the beautiful thing about a podcast.
You do.
You do whatever you want to do.
If you don't want to listen to this anymore,
go to radio lab.
It's an awesome show.
You ever heard about it?
There's one called dark codes.
It's out now.
I highly recommend it.
Oh uh,
Bill burrs,
Monday morning podcast.
Amazing.
Love Him.
Danieli Bolelli has a new podcast.
History on fire.
Go there.
Go there and they were everywhere.
Podcasts here and then I have
about
that.
Ooh,
baby.
Alrighty.
Yeah,
just dashawn and grow.
Ooh.
So a g gone and Dune.
Si
[inaudible]
but you all funny anything.
If you don't find p
Ooh,
baby.
[inaudible] gone and do Nah,
Eh,
changing
street.
Maybe Justin sleep.
Okay.
You know I don't give a damn liar.
She going to do now.
Oh
wait
from Louisiana?
No.
The dark and how it can harm you.
Yeah.
Bama Kuchins me apart.
Two.
Nah.
Okay.
Gotcha.
Oh
yeah,
it
God damn Suzanne,
you are bad mother.
Oh my God.
That's so good.
Cool.
Thanks so much for having me.
Good.
It's really fun.
Woo.
Have bottle of booze.
We got some good talks.
Good.
That song is,
you got to release that version too.
Oh God.
Oh,
that was awesome.
I want to do a record that's more stripped down.
I think that'd be awesome,
dude.
I'm not all do it all.
Do both kinds.
Keep
going.
Take Adderall to what you gotta do.
Keep it coming.
I want productivity.
Yes sir.
You guys are awesome.
That was really fun.
It's an honor.
It really is.
It's an honor to have you guys do that here.
So it's so cool.
It's a,
it's so whatever it is,
you know,
whatever you described something when someone just nails it.
That's what that just was.
It was like the song,
the lyrics,
the song,
the music,
the sounds,
the whole thing.
Ooh,
it's beautiful.
It's a work of art.
He should guys should be proud.
You're tapping into it.
Wherever the fuck it is.
Whatever you did to do that,
keep doing that shit.
You know,
whatever it is,
whatever path you're mind is on that made you guys create that.
That's good.
That's really good.
Really,
really,
really good.
You guys are the shit.
Yeah.
Um,
enough blowing.
You
tell people where they can see you alive and tell people how to get your shit.
It's all honey,
honey bands at the best way.
That's the portal for everything.
Instagram for Twitter,
for,
for all that shit.
And I'm like forum on our website too,
called talking shit.
We can like communicate with the people and we,
you know,
we we uh,
comment back six,
call it talking shit
because you can't,
you can't technically swear on it.
Which is weird cause we love is it to do that.
But it's,
it's talking to s h I t it a message board.
Why can't you swear on it?
I don't know.
I've tried.
I've tried to know it'll stop me every time I tried to send it so I have to
like,
and which makes me feel really uncomfortable because I feel very comfortable
with my potty mouth.
Is this here your own website?
You don't need that.
See that Ben?
Mine's called Shit talking.
Mine's called me about shit.
Talking one on one.
It's like the name of Jay.
You could,
you just change.
The filters are easy.
People can say whatever they want.
The only thing I tried to cut the racist stuff out.
How did that happen?
It's amazing.
Easy on filters,
on message boards.
You can set filters.
You could have him totally uncensored.
You can have people say what the fucks out of the cage.
There's a lot of them that come built in.
We tried to write fuck.
It'll give you like asterisk,
asterisk,
asterisk.
You know,
they say the people that swear a lot are more in touch with their truth and uh,
themselves.
Who said that?
A lot of people left those words.
Free bitches.
That's phrase.
Stop being a word.
Slave trade.
We're word slave.
Master.
Controlling those words that I'm all free,
right?
Do it live a raise home.
Well,
I'm glad we did two podcasts that way.
I don't feel that uncomfortable with you guys driving home.
I think we reached a,
a blood alcohol level of accepted this.
This was fun.
You guys hungry?
Let's get some room.
Alright,
honey.
Honey,
ban.com honey.
you ban Instagram,
honey band,
Twitter.
Do you guys keep individual Twitter?
No.
Hmm?
You like that weird married couple.
The chairs an email
maybe.
Oh,
I don't want to be,
I don't want to be the wedge.
I don't want to be the wedge in front of me.
Not in front of me.
Respect our friendship.
A goodnight.
You fucking freaks.
We'll be back soon.
Bye.